welcome back to the wonderful talented
Jasmine to our little podcaster in our
house I know we're like so completely
and excited I'm honored to have you here
you're like our first real guest that's
not my friend do you hang out with all
the time we just like rope our friends
into it they're like your first real
clearly don't don't be mistaken we're
friends now yeah yeah you don't have a
choice yeah I've already best of you had
thank you so much for coming on this
podcast is brought to you by Squarespace
our good friends at Squarespace make way
make making a website very easy so check
it out at squarespace.com for all your
website needs while Jenna tries to
swallow a candy 10% off your way I said
if you entered JJ at checkout at
squarespace.com I'll talk about more
later on so you're in town right now
yes are you so you're currently living
in London yeah I didn't okay and but
you're kind of always on the road right
now yeah I mean I travel like a lot
around Europe and then bobby was
spending two weeks here in LA so yeah
Cathy voice is magic I know I'm just
trying to get the best sound right yeah
like for those of you that don't know
that Jasmine Thompson is first of all go
home you're drunk
second of all Jasmine sinks and is
wonderful you just released your EP yes
adores those twelve yet I mean we've
downloaded it not to stop here or
anything but I was first introduced to
you because I have a radio show on
Sirius XM and you've been trending with
Robin Schulz for Sun Goes Down for like
a year like every day for a year we play
your song so I mean we did we made sure
yeah
in case you're not one of the hundred
and twenty five million people who's
watched that on YouTube the song Sun
Goes Down with Jasmine Thompson it has
been training for a long time yeah and
in fact it is the longest any song has
ever trended on genna's radio show so we
wanted to make it official thank you for
the longest written song to contain with
your name on it that's actually a trophy
it's real so that is uh I'd like to
thank my mother to me Annie
sitting in the corner right now I
wouldn't be you and how are you you're
like my mother
there you go yeah I was the most like my
thing everyone for you that the rest
were just like sports and I was like
that kind of would be out of place we
just got rolling a train or even like a
baseball it's not like a thing like you
know what's grounders sound rounders
yeah rounders
oh it's basically cricket but for those
maybe you just like will is like I
haven't hit anything around it I'm gonna
look it up and get really good at it I
doubt they had a rounders trophy I
didn't ask
well congrats that must be just insane
okay so you've had a very successful
turn in your music the last couple of
years and it's been crazy to watch and
your fortune yeah yeah 15 minutes worth
a birthday mm yeah but to have a song
take off like this I mean what like
initially when it starts against fire
and then it just doesn't stop like what
is that like for you and it's crazy
because you start it and you have no
idea where it's gonna go
I've done so many songs I just like run
a something on YouTube and like nothing
really happens to them but like with the
recent songs like tons of people are
hearing them and tons of you like
reacting to them and like sharing them
that means so much to me because like
music is something that I really want to
do like the rest of my life is like the
one thing that like I enjoy like it it
makes me feel stuff like I get so happy
um and just the fact that people like
the songs like make me so happy it was
really sweet my heart hurts she says my
heart anytime she gets the feels yeah
you have an extraordinary voice I know I
would say even for a grown woman you
have an extraordinary voice and you're
only 14 it's very distinctive like you
hear your voice and you don't mistake it
for anyone it's haunting in the best way
possible if that's like a weird
compliment Jana thank you Tom but like
completely unique and ridiculously like
enchanting your voice thing like um some
of the questions we're gonna get into
Twitter but like one of the good ones
you post a lot of videos to YouTube you
pose colors is that how you got your
start yeah well um yeah I first started
when you achieve when I was like 10 and
yeah we're good oh so fun cuz like
basically like neither me or my mom like
me have to use me instead like we were
just like my mom kind of like got like
an iPod and films me and like all this
stuff and like gradually and gradually
like after a certain amount of videos
like you just started exploring like
using an actual camera like recording
and stuff like that and then yeah we
just carried on doing it and then
suddenly like we we got a record deal we
started putting out songs like DJs and
all this stuff and yeah that's crazy and
you have you been on YouTube for over
four years yeah yeah and I mean I like a
lot of youtubers it takes a while to
build up just very little amount yeah I
watched the interview you were saying it
took you like two years to both up a
thousand socks and then one of your
songs pushed you over the 100k mark and
from there
it kind of just took off when you were
posting these songs was there at one
point where you posted a song and you
were like okay I think I think this can
keep going like I actually trust that I
can continue to put stuff out on this
platform and have it kind of carrying me
through um that was a point but it's
like always kind of subconsciously we
were just like when you don't post a
video for a while you're just like why
am i why am I not posting video like
this is fun like I want to do it it's
kind of just like I think one of my
covers which was a go I think that was
one of my biggest colors so that you
would say that was me yeah probably I
mean like tons of people would just like
tell you like oh my god I'm crying why
I'm missing two just like why am I
making you cry but it was so it's funny
it's funny that you brought it up I was
actually gonna bring that song up yeah
so I'm a huge fan of your covers I think
your covers are great
that was one of my favorites you've ever
done and I think it's very interesting
because this cover was used in Law &
Order SVU and I mean that in and of
itself is such a massive accomplishment
and those are the eyeballs on that you
know show are just insane
it's a very popular show but what was
interesting for me it was I watched that
before I knew it was you and then I
looked it up and I found it was you but
I watched that episode and it's so dark
and SV you can have these very graphic
and sad and touching moments where you
don't really know how to feel you're
feeling very strongly it's sad it's like
happy it's emotional but it was a very
sad sequence but the song somehow
carried this like beautiful like happy
nostalgic tone through the whole thing
and the original wouldn't have done that
it was the way that you sung it and I
think that's very I don't know when you
when they came to you and they were like
did they did they come to you and
they're like we were going to use your
song in this episode
I mean they asked something like okay
why would you do this
I understand it's good you yeah yeah
we're gonna it was your reaction when
the first time you saw but I was like
someone told me about it cuz I think is
like I mean I I didn't want it like
someone was just like oh yeah this girl
was like in a trunk and like she was
like the way she's explaining it's like
yeah I totally just made that cover tour
like staying through this really dark
girl getting kidnapped in [ __ ] so dark
but somehow it's not like traditionally
sad I don't know what did I mean it fit
really well yeah I don't know what
that's it could fit over a lot of things
a lot of your covers do on your YouTube
channel you have 225 million views and
1.7 million subscribers like that's
insane and it's not just that song you
have a lot of songs a lot of your covers
that get like 3 5 million 10 million the
one that I was most impressed with was
your Beyonce hey girl
where did you learn how to play guitar
like how do you play guitar
oh that's the only something that has to
play but something you know how to play
I guess if she's like playing it so
softly yeah when I play the guitar it
sounds like it's terrible yeah and it
hurts my fingers yeah baby yeah yeah
yeah I think it likes me take sounds
like 10 million owes it is by Beyonce
you know it's difficult to sing a
Beyonce song and do it justice I'm like
I was released haven't uncovered as long
as like it's Beyonce yeah tons of people
get really protective oh yeah imagine so
that guy was like really scared though
yeah how do you rushed it how do you
you've a lot of covers we also have your
original music you prefer one over the
other I do I mean okay obviously you
like one needs your original songs it's
like much more personal because you when
you write them it's coming from your own
like positive experience like all of
this stuff obviously I mean I'm for
Athena having had that much experience
so like I try and get like ideas from
like other people and then try and they
just to them as much as I can and that's
the thing with covers although I was
singing a song and I feel like connected
to it really it's like I never tried me
better in the original like person like
you don't say like no way am I ever
gonna try be better than her like my
other song like ain't nobody was covered
by Chaka Khan it's one of my favorite
songs ever
I believe you covered that song as
legend that's the thing I love the
original version and there's just like I
didn't try any better than her I just I
just wanted to show people a different
interpretation of the song because like
that her go is such like a it's such a
sweet song when you listen to it and
then like I just kind of turn it into a
document but I mean that that is the
beauty of covers you know you kind of
put a spin on something that already
exists which is cool I really like the
naughty boy cover the lalala because in
that song you hear it's like blah blah
and it's but it's very processed it's
very like and you're singing it right
there in your room you're singing that
long a lot part like I don't know I
can't even comprehend that but that was
a good one there's so many good cover
stuff and now you have your EP that's
out and you just launched an app yeah I
just released an app I mean I when I
first started never ever believe that I
would have like my own applications and
my friends like every single time it
took my friends it is like oh I love the
app Jasmine right I really do that see
me to pick you up something
that's pretty I'm just like it's a way
for me it's like get in touch with like
the really hardcore fans like that's
where I'll put like ticket sales or like
I'll give them stuff like before it's on
my Instagram or other social media
platforms like it's like exclusive
content like them stuff like that cuz I
mean if I post it every like 10 minutes
on Instagram like people would stop for
anything
yes so annoyed yes so like little rules
like that spam Instagram you can you
have snapchat though yeah its eyes
pretty fun is good to spam yeah
but that's what the app is for you can
just spam it and people actually enjoy
it
I want to ask you a question about like
because something that I've dealt with
coming from the internet and then going
into the real world is people like
automatically assume that like they can
just throw you into a very foreign
environment and that you're gonna be
like just fine so how did you find
transitioning from like recording a song
in your house alone to being on his
stage and probably a billion people like
was that scary at all
yeah it was really scary but as in like
I was really excited at the same time
like I was just like oh my god there's
so many people looking at me I think me
and my friend have my guitarist see
always has this joke like one day I came
into hostels and he was looking at me
when I sang and I was like and I got
really freaked out and then when I got
into like on stage and that was like 50
people looking at me I was like oh my
god my guitars is laughing his head off
and he knew I was thinking but it's just
like over the time link there's a really
big difference I'm like I did one gig I
like this small place called the ballet
in the UK and that was like owner like
under a hundred people in the room and
it was really sweet like it was just me
and my guitarist it was like really
acoustic and everyone was like paying
attention everyone was like looking at
you and it was really sweet other times
like switch to like a month ASA it was
in front of like 40,000 people and it
was like a massive sea of people it was
dark like you can see like that like
that firms like they were videoing
everything and like I could just see the
lights like bobbing up and down because
they
dancing ends up to relink it's crazy
like it was so much do you ever get
nervous at all before you perform
I mean it's like especially like I
always struggle to remember Derek got to
remember the lyrics my like I read
through them and all this stuff but then
it's like five minutes before I go
onstage I'll just like take a really
massive deep breath and feel like I'm
about to perform I'm about to do what I
love like I'm about to go onstage and
sing and be happy because it's like one
of those things where you go on and the
time just flies by but you don't think
oh I have to hit this note I have to
sing these lyrics they just come out
like it's really fun like that's what
music is supposed to be so that's why
it's that's amazing what was it I'm
nervous the whole time I'm ever in front
of like more than just Julie and I'm
like just better do something with my
hands I mean you're right you put a lot
of time so much time into your music and
when you get out to a point like that it
does fly your body goes into autopilot
because you've done it so many times but
you're just kind of doing it it's so
crazy though because the the Robin
Schulz song is like you know I does that
fall under the EDM category yeah so
you'd like you would sing acoustic songs
by yourself and then all of a sudden
Robin Schulz like hey let's do this
together and now you're at a festival we
can call that versatility pretty good
right no that's cool that's insane how
is it been working with him he's it was
a guy I mean like he's even Germany and
he doesn't really speak that much
English but like if he did see him
surely be really funny I could
understand what he was saying he's
really sweet and I'm so happy that like
he reached out to do the song with his
like before that I never ever like
dreamed about singing on an EDM track
cause like that's like a completely
different world through my YouTube's I
know doing the Robin so it's there have
been so many doors like without that
song I wouldn't have done it your body I
wouldn't have done like all of these
like new things that might be coming
that's so crazy to think
you like you you're born and bred in
this style and then you do one thing
that takes off and you're like well I
can do a completely separate style yeah
it's crazier yeah and you had another
song recently hit 100 million views all
right buddy yeah yeah crazy
and your new song adore number three in
Italy and Shazam yeah yeah I love how
you used to choose the am is like a
birthday but thanks for Shazam me so
what uh what's the coolest place you've
ever got to go for a performance or
otherwise hmm okay I really loved going
so my biggest performance was only
40,000 and that was in I think was in
bern in switzerland and i really loved
it i know i was like that was the place
like oh these like especially going to
germany like and then like seeing like
the people and like the culture and like
he's like places are crazy like that is
so amazing and filled with color and
filled with like happiness thank it's
really cool and it's what I like doing
especially when like going to LA or
going to New York to do like music is
the fact that when I started I was in my
bedroom in the UK in London and then
four years later I can go all the way to
LA and people I can connect with people
that I've never met and still we still
have the same thing which is music like
that's why I love me that so much with
his like especially when writing the
song you'll go into a session for
someone and you won't know them at all
and then by the end of the day like you
know that darkest secrets like you know
like the funniest sort of like everyone
to them like you get to meet so many
interesting people all the time yeah I'm
in the school of thought that singing is
one of the most vulnerable things you
can do like I write like writing your
feelings and thoughts and then singing
them like riddle me something more
vulnerable I don't want to do that I'm
terrified
that's scary I'm sorry I'm kind of a
baby
that makes a lot of sense it's a
cultural language you can connect with
people that's and that's so cool it's
and you know you're speaking Universal
when you can use like sit down with
someone for a day and you really do you
see like the deepest parts of their soul
like instantly and like oh my best
friends know know each other do that's
very cool
it's really cool yeah and take a quick
break right now
talk about Squarespace it's quite fast
Squarespace calm for your website needs
if you guys are looking to build a
website for your online shop your blog
your music go to Squarespace calm and
check it out they have awesome templates
it looks beautiful and it's a seamless
process you can make your website you
can add anything you want to and it
comes with a shop you have 24/7 customer
support and you get 10% off of your
first website if you use product code
jayjay at checkout Squarespace is a
proud sponsor of the gen ed Julien pod
Hey and a few of any questions shown at
squarespace.com you will love it and
guarantee it Squarespace is amazing
thank you guys for really supporting us
for letting us have the cool thing and
so we do inter questions yeah we got
some Twitter question
so we can do them as fast as you watch
it alright this one comes from Presley
Horton with two N's
what is your opinion on leggings
leggings do you wear leggings I never
wear leggings really yeah I only wear
leggings I mean it's like they really
comfy but you can't wear them outside
because I knew you can't sweat cold and
also like they're really thin and
sometimes you can see your underwear as
you came here it's like nighttime right
now and it's still 85 degrees I know
what she looks
incredible she's wearing like this long
cape and I'm like okay um Daugherty
Jenna don't be awkward majority
underscore Arthur wants to know your
favorite artists at the moment or what's
on your playlist I love the group I
wonder I love that song livewire and the
rain and shark and who else do I like I
love Justin Bieber at the moment yeah
actually we're talking about that a
couple podcasts ago I put out some cool
stuff second I feel all of that do you
know who to remix with a wonder that
I've used in my vlogs hmm no no I use
his kid named mouth piece of music he's
like a EDM producer ever and he collabs
with Wonder yeah awesome I'm gonna hear
it do you ever run into any trouble like
when you make covers you ever had like
Taylor Swift feel like you need to
delete this oh no no never never nothing
that's awesome maybe that's a rumor the
Taylor Swift wanted people to like
delete their finds well I don't happen
Dawson's meet you what are you crazy
Oh magical yeah okay I have another
question who is there anyone that you
would want to work with or that you
haven't met that you okay so as I will
make you and Shane happen at any time
girl gotcha these are you too busy oh my
god
I love Tyler Oakley really fun like all
of these he's sorry Troy is the real
deal I heard while he it's good we
listen it because we were we were with
him in Australia recently he's magical
yeah he's he looks like more beautiful
in person than I'll look on my wedding
day and I said to his face and I made it
weird but he's like unbelievably
talented and funny yes so yeah and Tyler
Tyler is always like the most
charismatic person anyway insane but you
watching youtubers yeah look I mean my
friends like whenever she can my friend
Kat whenever she comes around to my
house like we always like watch like
tons of like YouTube vlogs and stuff
like that and we just been like the
whole time not talking to like not
talking to each other yeah she was
having a sleepover with us like this
other guys she was like she was like hey
jazz was talking you have all right this
question comes from Sydney on kafir one
I don't know do you have any pets yes I
have a cat yeah yeah she's good Lily
she's older than me but yeah yeah she's
15 16 years Wow yeah Lily's an old lady
yeah she's really old go Willy
yeah very young mostly on your Instagram
yeah no one's here in scrims for yeah
wait so she lives at home yeah so you
miss her
yeah what do you do if you don't have
your kitty like who do you hug Annie
just making some cat noises do you bring
home say um
are you like excited to travel yeah I
mean like timing is like great but his
like I think my mom with me as I do with
my heart hurts cuz owl sitting that
she's saying that was ah I know it
sounds like she just got punched not an
American oh you missed it last week we
did a podcast where we guessed slang
from the UK it was a lot of fun we got
everything wrong yes like oh that's fine
yeah like like Jasmin's EP it's [ __ ]
fireman I drop my mixtape it's fire
let's cool the fire down what was the
other word that you said we said I got
confused with the meaning of mad like
something like oh I'm not mad about that
means like either they love it or they
like they don't hate people say things
like oh that song is mad good very good
sometimes it's like a double negative
for it
yeah that's confusing people call things
that they really like nasty here so
they're oh that's nasty
why would you call that nasty Oh things
I mean if you came up with that [ __ ]
nobody
all right this question comes from wild
Kaitlyn Kaitlyn with the why ask her
what her personal favorite song off her
EP is I my faith you have one probably
it would be a great escape you just put
on video for that three days ago yeah
yeah nothing we are in the car yeah we
didn't stock it okay from Tyler Oakley V
what inspires you to keep moving forward
with your music with a purple heart
sorry favorite color yeah good color
good color I'll only be knows you well
purple per block yay
what inspires you to keep moving forward
new music um the fact that is the only
thing that I really like to do it's like
music is my way of like giving out my
feelings really it's like does is with
feeling if I don't sing for a really
long time let me get really like I just
hate it I'm just like something's all
right I'll feel really would it's like
yeah some people write in their diary
some people write poetry some people go
on Twitter and make a really big run I
kind of just like sing you do it in a
beautiful way what everyone else I feel
the same way cuz I'm like oh you know
what I need to do right now it's
something really weird on the internet
yeah I get you you just have energy in
you that you gotta get out yeah and
something was done some people add some
before yeah some people just hate their
life cuz they can't figure out how to
get it out yeah
you're somewhere to channel it and yeah
just like I'll channel it to like a
hundreds of millions of people every
Daniel durables that's an adorable name
do you believe in aliens alien facepiece
emojis oh yeah yes yeah I like you so
now that you said yes to that you are
going to come back and have a podcast
with Jesse are you talking about aliens
and she said let's do it I think they're
so good I just want to be their friend I
think more like more than 50% of our
podcasts we talked about aliens you know
I can't help it I love them
fair enough okay pixel livestream wants
to know how does she find a balance
between doing covers and original songs
well for the past four years like so I
did I mean like how do I know like what
do i how do you like to balance how do
you feel like when's it's time for a
couple - time for an original so okay
what I used to do is I used to post like
a cover like every other week reasonably
because we've been like traveling more
and doing all this stuff like I've been
focusing a lot on like my music like the
reason why I'm in LA is to do like tons
of writing sessions like um so the thing
is now I try post a cover like once a
month
I'll try original songs like obviously
like the process of putting out an
original song is there any long diet
complicated yeah okay the songs from the
EP I think I wrote most of them like in
January like you're really long time
things like get hours you tough so I
have a lot of like something to like put
out so yeah like when I can almost
recover and when I when I can office
like yes or whatever in fixed time in
your life yeah or if you hear a song we
were like I'm covering yeah
and then SVU just steals it they're
selfish okay
Paris underscore for ribs wants to know
what is your favorite holiday
oh ah okay and your ladies the old ones
in the UK no yeah okay it's like really
dodgy I mean I wish I would G I love the
Y's does your daddy can you explain what
doggies you tell us what dodgy I always
say I always say don't do you like if I
hit like a really bad nut bag oh my god
that was so Georgie and like you shifty
shifty shifty shifty shifty yeah shift
these various I feel like it's similar
to Taj if you meet a person and you like
get a weird feeling you're like that was
shifting you would say that okay yeah I
mean I think I'm the only person that
says dodgy because I've never had my
friends there so maybe is just a Jazz's
oh yeah what was the question
your favorite holiday was what was dodgy
me I love I love Halloween but I could
never really do it well I mean I never
really did it I don't even drink oh geez
in Wharton's
and like yeah well she's kind of not
living the normal 14 year old like oh
well sister what are you where are you
gonna be following this show are you
gonna be home um buzz oh no no I'm gonna
be oh yeah I've been there before
yeah that's why we showed the music
ain't nobody actually that's right
that's right that's right
do you are you gonna dress up for
Halloween or anything I mean beyond
space yeah that's it for how she's come
out as a pumpkin
I'll sing for you but I'm gonna be a
pumpkin nobody in this town is just out
there like in Spain we all dress up
you're disrespecting everyone another
question again from wild Kaitlyn wants
to know in all capital letters ask her
how she has such hair goals oh my god
with the hair down so you don't do
anything special you just go yeah yeah
wash it every other day I got a [ __ ]
tour this year which means once a year
yeah that's your secret though yeah it
doesn't have a cut it makes perfect
sense got it have you enjoyed it's a
great well what's here it's like a
little bit so it's like huh but they
don't grow I used to not cut my hair
ever excited just couldn't afford it but
it like stops growing like here but like
Aries is like I mean I think she's just
genetically more talented in the hair
than less people I think the answer
goals where you're not talented in the
hair
alright Lanie underscore gents wants to
know I go to a school of art where I
major in vocal I was wondering how much
and what kind of vocal training you had
um so I
I had singing lessons since I was like 8
years old
yeah just like I had like saying that
sounds like once a week since I was 8
like I used to my old school was um
before I was home-schooled I went to
like a theater school where we did like
singing and acting and dancing and all
this stuff so like majority of my time
when it's like spent learning like
singing and stuff it was very fun that's
cool so you do have formal training yeah
yeah that's cool you just woke up one
day baby
no it's me okay underscore now wants to
know how is your cat we do any we talked
about Louise do for you have okay you
should set up a live camera those are
the Twitter questions I have is there
anything that you want to talk about the
URL model that you want to obviously you
guys can get her EP right now on iTunes
yeah Dora will link everything jasmine
description for info on snapchat it's
Jasmine snaps with a Z right yes oh yeah
you guys easy as that is ed then tantrum
jazz on Twitter Thank You jazz because
she just threw a tantrum on our podcast
and jazz Matassa and YouTube babe yeah
Daniel yeah no just go to youtube and
type AJ yeah
I'll be like thank you so much for
coming on the podcast
l said you want to talk about a promo
whatever you want whatever I want
yeah yeah yeah I got secrets yeah I have
that secret download her app that's like
watch her cat oh yeah okay enough people
down the pre Lily beta right now you
can't see Lily yet it really is gonna be
messy
yes yeah it's um here's nothing else
that you know that you could talk about
right now I mean like okay so what
happens is I go home Ghostbuster gonna
come back and then I'll be on tour with
a lady called yeah so I'm doing a couple
of shows with her in the UK yeah and
apart from that I can't tell you okay so
here you guys just have to stay tuned to
her life to find out my secret news that
only Annie knows yeah nobody else just
like told you
if you see some sort of answer yeah now
you know you guys can follow her
everything in the description below
go get her EP right now it's absolutely
beautiful and followed her stuff on
YouTube because she does still post
covers and original music on there thank
you again for joining us very honestly
this is the most nervous we had been
we're so nervous know what to do with my
hands the whole real quick thank you to
Squarespace for sponsoring the podcast
or the squarespace.com right now for
your website needs best websites in the
business easiest to use use jayjay at
checkout for 10% off Thank You
Squarespace and thank you guys and for
coming yeah you learned a fair and
square that you won fair and square
everyone but yeah I mean it's been
wonderful it's been a pleasure
yeah we should let you go do your big
awesome I'm just going to say we have
them here that's a good choice well good
luck to everything you do in the future
any time you want I'm just gonna no good
you know you like
don't think we just don't walk on girl
come on yeah
Jasmine has special treatment we don't
walk about how much thank you guys for
watching check her stuff out
[Music]